my name is Julia hran and I am working
with Katherine DeWolf and John Ox andorf
in the Department of Civil and
environmental engineering and we are
looking at the embodied carbon content
of buildings so with increasing
awareness about global warming and
climate change a lot of efforts have
been made to decrease the uh energy
consumed by buildings but that's really
in in like increasing Energy Efficiency
so decreasing the electricity used bya
like passive lighting passive heating
things like that but what that neglects
is the uh energy consumed in the
production of the materials that go into
building the building so the concrete
the structural steel Etc so that's what
we're looking to do so we're looking at
determining the embodied carbon content
which is what that's called of low uh
energy buildings so buildings such as
lead which are determined to be energy
efficient it the lead certifications
actually really don't account for the uh
energy consumed in the mining of these
materials so we're looking at uh the
amount of materials used the types of
materials because um so the global
warming content is the number of
material the amount of material used U
multiplied by the amount of carbon
dioxide emitted per kilogram produced